close your eyes and pray for salvation
we're returning to the lanky lethal lad
whose rampages often result in legendary
losses of life it's
scp-096 the shy guy long-time fans of
the channel will no doubt know this
anomalous monster like the back of their
hand after all we have several videos on
the subject that are definitely worth
checking out sometime but to get the
full benefit of today's tale we'll do a
quick refresh for any potential
newcomers in the audience good to have
you here let's start with the basics the
first thing you'll probably notice about
096 is its daunting size and rather
unusual bodily proportions while mostly
humanoid in shape the shy guy has long
dangling arms that almost reach the
ground its body is thin and hairless
with opaque clear white pupillous eyes
and a wide gaping mouth it is a truly
chilling sight to behold an abomination
that conjures up nightmares just to look
at it and we mean that literally you
don't want to look at this thing and
we'll get to why in a moment
scp-096 doesn't really do much during an
average day usually this tall spindly
humanoid entity will spend its downtime
just aimlessly pacing around in its
containment cell and perhaps
occasionally taking a nap pretty
relatable right especially if you've
been trapped in your college dorm room
during the lockdown but if some unlucky
soul should dare to look at scp-096
specifically its horrible face that's
when the monster starts to act very
differently now someone doesn't have to
be directly looking at scp-096 to make
this happen even glancing at a blurry
distorted photo of it or watching
security footage of the creature can
have the same deadly result you see the
moment
scp-096's face is seen the wiry monster
will know
when this happens the creature suffers
what appears to be a psychological
meltdown covering its face with its huge
claw-like hands and weeping hence the
nickname shy guy utterly inconsolable
and suffering from extreme emotional
distress eventually the creature will be
unable to take it anymore standing up
scp-096 will then travel towards whoever
dared to look at it using anomalous
speed to hunt down the person that saw
its face the foundation has proven that
it is unquestionably impossible for
anyone to hide from scp-096
literally nothing can stand in its path
as it tracks down its victim not walls
or locked doors even being aboard a boat
in the middle of the ocean or in a plane
in mid-air can prevent it from finding
you and when it does find you it's not a
pleasant sight
scp-096 will kill the person that looked
at it without leaving any detectable
trace on their body the monster is
impervious to gunfire and all other
forms of conventional weaponry it can't
be killed or even so much as harmed even
if the shy guy is only seen as a tiny
little speck in a photograph this will
be enough to trigger the creature's
relentless defense mechanism so because
of this the scp foundation's only real
way to keep the creature safely locked
up is in an airtight steel cube with no
security cameras or surveillance tools
of any kind all members of personnel are
reminded that they are to never ever
look at it but what if they could what
if somehow someone was able to
neutralize
scp-096's anomalous abilities or was
resistant to being killed when the
creature inevitably tracked them down
this is how the tale known as picture
perfect begins what do you think boys is
she a beauty or what dr kleff proclaimed
to a group of his fellow high-ranking
foundation researchers the group looked
in confusion and unease at what clef had
been referring to namely a photograph
that he just hung up on the wall of his
office a photo of what though well a
four foot by five foot picture of none
other than
scp-096 of course naturally the other
researchers shared a mixture of shock
and dismay at what clef had just done as
you would if one of your co-workers hung
up a photo of a creature that could kill
you just for looking at that said photo
we've lost a number of staff members
from around the scp-explained office
that same way let's just say the
christmas party last year was not that
fun dr klaff had long been one of the
more enigmatic and mysterious scientists
working at the foundation with the
exception of the elusive and infamous o5
council alto clef was formerly an
operative for the global occult
coalition as well as being known to be a
bit of a gun enthusiast and all-around
crazy wild card clef earned his own
brand of infamy for his rumored practice
of brutally decommissioning dangerous
scps and you can probably guess what we
mean by that he's the foundation's go-to
executioner and a specialist in dealing
with reality bending anomalies would you
expect any less from an ex-goc joining
clef in his office were the likes of dr
jack bright another infamous foundation
researcher dr bright also known as
scp-963-2 was assigned to conduct
experiments on an anomalous amulet as cp
963 which resulted in his death at the
hands of scp-076
abel however anomalous properties of the
amulet gave bright the ability to
inhabit new bodies after his death
specifically anyone who also touches the
amulet which kills the host and allows
bright to take control of their body
while technically immortal dr bright
isn't exactly stoked about that fact
often seeking out death and wanting to
know exactly what it feels like also
present at the unveiling of dr cliff's
photo of scp-096 was his friendly rival
dr kondraki while usually gruff and
antisocial kondraki is an expert in
perception based anomalies normally
called upon by the foundation to
photograph scps that would otherwise be
invisible or imperceivable dr sumerian a
member of the foundation's ethics
committee was also in the room as dr
cleff proudly showed off his office's
latest decoration perhaps the most
outwardly strange researcher in
attendance was kane pathos crow a
scientist from the foundation's research
department who had been transformed into
a labrador retriever after an experiment
that needless to say went a bit awry
crow must have been barking up the wrong
tree on that one each of them expressed
their reactions differently deeply
exasperated dr sumerian shook his head
and began to question his recent
decision to stop drinking meanwhile dr
bright looked up at the painting with a
bemused tilting of his head he wondered
if scp-096 would come to kill him and if
it did would it only do so once or would
the creature try again and again each
time that bright inhabited a new body
perhaps in an attempt to look away from
the photo kane lowered his head and
covered his snout with a paw while dr
kondraki hung his head in deep
disappointment the only one among the
group that seemed unaffected by the
sight of the scp-096 photograph was dr
charles gears another high-ranking scp
foundation scientist it was gears who
finally broke the uncomfortable silence
asking dr cleff the one question that
had been on everyone's minds
why clef excitedly exclaimed that the
photo was meant to be in celebration of
scp-096 finally having been neutralized
and according to the scientists they
were free to look the creature's ugly
mug all they wanted the group stared in
horror at the gaping mouth the screaming
expression of the monster that had
killed so many people not one of them
shared in dr cleff's enthusiasm some
like bright and gear simply argued that
the picture was creepy while others
voiced far greater concerns kane argued
that putting up a photo of scp-096 was
in poor taste that it was massively
disrespectful to all the unwitting
victims that the shy guy had killed over
the years it was also reckless and
dangerous dr sumerian added it had not
yet been a full 24 hours since
scp-096's apparent death and if the
creature was somehow able to come back
to life it could kill every researcher
in the office by showing them this
so-called masterpiece clef had put all
of his co-workers lives at risk he
showed off their concerns of the
creature coming back to life despite
knowing that this was entirely possible
after all it wasn't just anomalies and
scps that could defy death most of the
foundation's higher ranking staff were
also capable of the same even some of
the researchers in that very room had
died at least once dr kleff claimed that
should the worst happen in scp-096
return to life they could simply forget
its face with amnestics clef claimed
that they were now free of
scp-096's anomalous powers thanks to the
creature's termination but the four men
and one dog in his office with him
failed to share his enthusiasm the group
then began debating why the foundation
even needed to neutralize scp-096 in the
first place with its containment purely
hinged on nobody ever looking at the
creature he could be contained by
putting a sack over his head dr bright
pointed out met with murmurs of
agreement from the others that's where
you're wrong jack there could be photos
of him from before he was contained or
someone could get a hold of the photos
we already have of him dr cliff argued
back if they did something like hack
markiplier's youtube account put that
photo on the homepage it'd be game over
the shy guy would breach containment
with millions of dash ones to kill all
over the world and that kind of rampage
would guarantee he'd have cameras
pointed on him 24 7. exposure would grow
exponentially until the bastard
slaughtered most of the civilization as
far as i'm concerned he should have been
classified as ketter from the star but
bright argued back stating that the
foundation had no real cause to kill
scp-096
they already had a clear understanding
that the shy guy's anomalous behaviors
were only even triggered by somebody
observing it and preventing that from
happening was pretty easy killing the
creature just seemed excessive cruel
even sumerian chimed in again saying
that killing scp-096 was something the
global occult coalition would do and the
foundation still hadn't learned all they
could about zero nine six could someone
survive looking at the creature if they
were in space or another dimension now
no one would ever know on top of that dr
gears pointed out that the foundation
had no clue what
scp-096's exact origin was where the
creature had come from if it was the
only one of its kind or whether it was a
part of a species of similar monsters if
more beings like the shy guy could exist
in the future they could cause a global
catastrophe but despite all the points
raised by his colleagues dr cleff didn't
want to hear any of what they had to say
all right i hear what you're all saying
but shut up the shy guy was a sword of
damocles dangling over the whole world
we killed him and we're gonna celebrate
that by doing the one thing we could
never do while he was alive looking at
his face each and every day for the rest
of our lives so that we never forget
what we've won and could have lost the
four researchers and the one who had
been turned into a dog all took a moment
to consider clef's argument more
courtesy than he had extended to them
they all looked up at the haunting
grotesque face of scp-096 once more as
much as they protested the decision to
have the creature killed each of them
secretly hoped it stayed neutralized
especially now that clef was using
scp-096's photo as an office decoration
if the creature ever managed to come
back anyone that set foot in cleft's
office and looked at the picture was as
good as dead finally dr kondraki spoke
up and threatened to resign cleft to one
of the worst positions imaginable
critiquing first drafts of scp reports
by junior researchers for a moment clef
thought his rival was bluffing but
eventually decided it was better to be
safe than sorry as the gunhow foundation
scientist begrudgingly pulled the photo
from his office wall he muttered to the
group none of you appreciate post-modern
art now go check out scp-096 shy guy
escape incident
096-1-8 containment breach at scp-096
look at a picture of shy guy in space
the shy guy questions and theories for
more on the legendary shy guy